he's a symbol for Venezuela's opposition
Leopoldo Lopez led the first major
movement against Nicolas Maduro that was
over five years ago the protests ended
in failure and Lopez's detention
fast forward to Tuesday Lopez escapes
from house arrest he says soldiers freed
him it's the beginning of the latest
military uprising against Maduro one
that so far has again failed to dislodge
Venezuela's leader right now once more
Leopoldo Lopez is confined this time to
the Spanish Embassy but the opposition
leader says his stay there won't be long
because Venezuela's leadership he
believes is poised to switch sides I've
been meeting with commanders with
generals I have been holding talks with
the different factions of the military
and we agreed to put an end to this
usurpation of power but Nicolas Maduro
has been trying to show he still
commands the troops loti he dressed
scores of them at the Caracas Military
Academy on stage with him some of the
leadership a signal that they're
literally behind him but the leader also
sees rebellion in the ranks we cannot
give one inch to the traitors to the
conspirators we must go on the offensive
and be active everyone must follow the
command and detain any traders still
Maduro supporters are pains to sound a
harmonious note after days of turmoil
the tune from the government Maduro is
still number one but would the loyalty
of his army far from assured Tuesday's
discord could very well be reprised well
Europe has been criticized for its
relative silence this week regarding
events in Venezuela earlier we spoke to
Andrei of snick he is a member of the
German parliament with Chancellor
Merkel's CDU party and he sits on the
Foreign Affairs Committee I think we
have a clear position that un gato is
the legitimate interim president of
Venezuela in accordance with the
Constitution of Venezuela we call on
everyone involved to refrain from
violence and seek a peaceful solutions
through a national dialogue and a
democratic transition that can only be
resolved through a fair and free
elections and to enable that and to make
that possible I think Maduro has to step
aside I think there were rumors last
couple of days he was already plotting
his refuge to Cuba not clear how
realistic that scenario is but it's
clear that neither Maduro guy do at the
moment can can secure the full support
of the of the authorities in in
Venezuela so that statement may continue
for quite a while I think we have been
strongly supportive of all the countries
in the region in the Lima crew working
together for a peaceful transition in
the country we should never forget that
there's a refugee crisis with more than
10 percent more than 3 million people
and Prime Minister I would have left
that country into all neighboring
countries of the region which is a
significant risk of destabilizing the
region as a whole so we strongly support
our partners in Colombia Ecuador Peru
and other countries who involved in
there I was in the region myself in
February together with a federal
president and we support in terms of
giving refuge to the people fleeing -
leyla in terms of securing humanitarian
support for those remaining in Venezuela
and in working towards a peaceful
transition and I think once it gets
going we can be even more helpful in
terms of supervising and monitoring as
he with you facilities and election
process it should be fair and legitimate
and produce a new government for
Venezuela and that was ondrea's Nick
they're speaking with us he's a member
of the German parliament and sits on the
Foreign Affairs Committee so where are
we now in two minutes whele to talk
about that I'm joined by Francisco
Marquez he is a political adviser to
opposition leader Juan Cueto Francisco
was in prison
by President Nicolas Maduro for four
months after his release he left the
country he joins me tonight from
Washington DC Francisco welcome it's
good to have you back on the program
I know that you've been answering this
question today from a lot of people and
it's still relevant tonight explain the
last 48 hours to us was this a political
gamble that did not pay off well I would
actually argue that we've seen the
highest level of defections in the last
48 hours than we've ever had during this
process I always called to mind manuel
christopher he was the director of
intelligence of the regime and it is
widely known fact that he contributed
and coordinated with president wydo and
just to give you another effect the
highest level political prisoner of the
regime Leopoldo Lopez was also able to
leave the house arrest and he's
currently on the street just like Juan Y
dough if this was such a coup d'etat or
if the module has full control of
security forces wise president y dos
still on the street still practicing
politics still trying to restore
constitutional order so my argument and
president y dos argument is that we've
actually moved forward and Maduro is
weaker and now than he was 48 hours ago
francisco do you know how many soldiers
nel support one why doe well for
strategic purposes we can get into that
but i can tell you that the majority of
the security forces are with president y
dough and it's no secret we have to be
very upfront with the people that there
are still some security forces with the
regime that's not a surprise but what
has surprised many people is the level
of support the president Widodo has for
security forces and we will continue to
see more defections as days and and
moving forward for sure but that so
that's something you can confirm that
the majority of soldiers the majority of
the military is now with one guido yes
as we have stated before the transition
is a process this these sometimes take
unfortunately more time that we would
like but if I would have told you two
weeks
go that the director of intelligence of
the regime was was in coordination with
interim president why doe you probably
would not have to leave me but now
that's a fact and it's so true that
they've just replaced him with another
figure and just like it's true the
module right now is surrounded by people
that promised that he would he would
leave that day this is a complicated
issue but rest assure that the people of
Venezuela millions of people on the
street support president mido and that's
what's most important whydo arts and
where doe has the people's interest in
all his policies and in everything he's
trying to do francisco how do you
explain the military parade that we saw
today in caracas with nicolas maduro he
was standing there with his top military
men beside him yeah and and i invite you
to if you can post that clip where the
Ministry of Defense says that people
were trying to buy him off and the
surprise face of the regime of Nicolas
Maduro this was an act a show Maduro is
weaker than he's ever been and anybody
can paint a picture with a couple of
security forces around him and that's
what Maduro is trying to do but the fact
of the matter is he's lost control and
as I mentioned before your Bulldog Lopez
the top political prisoner left his
house and he was surrounded by
intelligence officials and counter
military counterintelligence and he left
with no problem that's because they
followed interim president widows order
Francisco I'm gonna ask you there are
reports that opposition leaders spent
months in secret talks with top Maduro
officials including Venezuela's defense
minister mister Padrino Lopez I mean did
those talks really take place yes I can
confirm that on behalf of president wide
oh and as we have said before there are
other talks this is not this is only the
tip of the iceberg as we have mentioned
before international pressure and
domestic pressure is working it is
creating the conditions for more and
more defections and more fractures is
and that's why the pressure will
continue it's the u.s. is the United
States is it taking part in these talks
as well
this is a venezuelan led movement by the
Venezuelan people and for the Venezuelan
people it's the same reason that on
Jerry January 23rd when president y dos
swore oath to office we had the support
of more than 20 countries that day
obviously the u.s. supported us but now
we have more than 56 countries so
everything we're doing is Venezuelan LED
but definitely supported by the
international community what about the
speculation that the opposition may have
been tricked by mr. Padrino and and
others close to mid Maduro into thinking
that a deal was being put into place I
mean is where you guys set up I don't
believe that's the case again look at
the support this was a nationwide
movement by security forces this is only
the tip of the iceberg and we will
definitely see how everything plays out
in the next couple days in next couple
weeks as the pressure continues as we
said before
Maduro surrounded by people that wanted
his head on a platter and he knows that
now and now it's public I want to ask
you what about what Elliott Abrams the
US envoy for Venezuela he he claims that
the u.s. did not take part in the
negotiations between the opposition and
members of the Maduro regime but he says
there is a document that talks about a
plan for Maduro leaving have you seen
that document i cannot comment on that
matter but what i can say is that talks
between high-level regime officials and
interim president why doe did take place
and that those talks were significant
and in those talks these regime
officials promised that Maduro would be
out and as i said before this is a
complicated and complex process mm-hmm
but in the following weeks in the
following days we will see more to come
we we've got a soundbite of the US
president he was talking today about
Venezuela let me see if we can play that
right now take a listen to what he said
about Venezuela I'd like to begin
sending our prayers to the people of
Venezuela in their righteous struggle
for freedom the brutal repression of the
Venezuelan people must end and it must
end soon people are starving they have
no food they have no water and this was
once one of the wealthiest countries in
the world so we wish them well we'll be
there to help and we are there to help
we wish them well does that sound like a
US president he was ready to go to bat
for you Francisco what are you hearing
from the White House we definitely think
the prayers of the President and the
Venezuelan people and all the world and
I just like to say this has been a
bipartisan issue for the last years and
right now we have the full support of
the United States government to restore
democracy in Venezuela so the commitment
is strong from the US and from the most
Latin America today we've seen more and
more comments by Colombia and by Lima
group members then they will support
president window in everything he's done
and I would just like to highlight very
quickly the unprecedented unprecedented
nature of what you've seen we saw an
interim president ordering security
forces to restore constitutional order
against a usurping regime and the most
of the international community in Latin
America supported this movement there
was no condemnation and there was no
violence during this situation so that
is very rare and unprecedented and so we
we have the full support phrasal
embassies in our region and in the world
before we run out of time then we just
want to ask you do you believe that
Nicolas Maduro is holding on to power
with the help of Russia there are
definitely bad actors in Venezuela just
like Cuba and Russia and this is a fact
but I would like to say on Russia that
Russia is not a monolith there are
high-level officials in Russia that are
definitely not pleased with how some
people are handling the Venezuelan
situation in Russia it is in the very
interest of Russia and China to restore
democracy in Venezuela because the fact
of the matter is that Russia or China
will never get its investment back
under the Maduro regime it will have an
open and frank discussion with the
democratic forces in the future once
democracy is restored
Francisco Marquez political adviser to
Venezuela's opposition leader 1yj
Francisco we appreciate you taking the
time to talk with us tonight I hope we
talk again soon thank you